welcome to pi
data
global 2021 my name is zea and i will be
your host for this session our presenter
is marcus learning
he is one of the core developers of
skype time
a unified python frame framework for ml
with time series
he recently finished his phd at ucl
and now he's working as a data scientist
during his phd he spent nine months at
the alan
turing institute
his research focuses on ml
time series and analysis and soft
software design
okay thank you there for the
introduction
and welcome everyone
this is the the sk time tutorial
i'm very glad to be here and i'm really
looking forward to the next 90 minutes
um
yes so
this is uh
to set the expectations this is a
beginner friendly tutorial so we assume
[Music]
some familiarity with the common pi data
stack including pandas and psychic
learner numpy
but not much more beyond that so you
don't need any previous experience of
working with time series
and we also like to
make this as interactive as possible
and this is sometimes a bit hard
on on zoom but we encourage you to ask
questions and chat with us
um
run the notebooks locally
on binder um i will share the the link
um
in the chat
um so that you can just play around with
the code and get to know us a little bit
and
you know find out more about sk time and
how to use it
um
[Music]
and
in order to facilitate this we have um
four helpers from the sk time community
in the chat
um so that should be
um
there should be plenty of people um to
give you answers in case you get stuck
um or to ask for more info
in case i i skip over things okay so
for today
the plan is um as follows um we first
want to give you an intro to machine
learning with time series
and to some extent that will be a
summary of the
tutorial from last year
um
so if you want to learn more about this
i think it makes sense to go back to
this
and in particular you will learn about
the the different learning problems that
you encounter when you work with time
series
you will learn about algorithms that can
help you solve these learning problems
and different ways
how you can build machine learning
models
and that includes both specialized time
series algorithms but also ways how you
can reuse um cycle learn to solve these
problems
and then while while the tutorial is
focused on users
um there will be a lot of lots of
comments on software design decisions
that we've taken
and how you can as a user extend escape
time so that you can implement your own
algorithms
which you may need for your projects
and i should also say that this is not
an introduction to
algorithms
but more of an intro to a software
framework
and so we will show you how you can use
different algorithms within sk time and
how you can
combine them with other packages
but we will not um say a lot about
how these different algorithms work
internally
um
and we will have two smaller breaks in
between and to give you a chance to ask
questions of course but also to move
around a bit
um
and finally before we get started um
sk time is still a relatively young
toolbox we started a bit over two years
ago now i think
so some features are still experimental
and they still need to be consolidated
and
especially over the year we've made
great progress so it's slowly maturing
but there's still lots of work that
needs to be done
and that makes it even more important
for you to give us feedback um and to
tell us if anything is missing that you
you know any feature that you really
like to see
or if things are not working
um okay so
i'm going to switch over to the
notebooks now
um
so can you still see my screen
can you see the the github repository
yes yes okay
great okay
um
so this is the
um the github repository that we're
gonna be using today
the link was just posted in the in the
chat um
and you can find the notebooks um in the
notebooks folder
and so that three three notebooks and
one
python file for utility functionality
and then you can also
find the link to binder so if you want
to run these notebooks in the cloud
without having to install anything you
can just click on this link and it will
open
a binder
notebook for you
now i'm running these locally
and i've
opened the first notebook here so the
one intro
and
[Music]
yes so before we dive into machine
learning with time series i think it
makes sense to um
start with
scikit-learn because i assume that this
is what
everyone will be familiar with
and um if you're unfamiliar with psychic
learn they have really good
documentation so you can check out their
getting started guide
um as an example data said um
we look at the diabetes data and we here
have um
so we can load this in
and we see
our feature data
and it's a data frame
and each row here represents a different
patient and each column represents a
different kind of measurement that we
have from the patients
and in addition we have a target
variable
which is y
that we would like to predict from the
variables that we have here
[Music]
and of course we can plot this so here i
plot two variables
and on the y-axis you have our target
variable that we want to predict in this
case it's the disease progression
and on the x-axis we plot one of the
measurements
namely a blood zero measurement and this
column um
and the typical workflow for this is
that you
specify model
you then fit the model
um once you have a fitted model you can
generate a
prediction and once you have a
prediction you'd like to evaluate the
prediction so that you have an idea of
how well the model would perform
in the real world in the actual
deployment situation that you're trying
to solve
so inside kit learn
we do this as follows
well first of all before specifying the
model we split our data into training
and testing
sets
and and then we specify our model and
this happens on this line and i think
this is this will be familiar to most of
you so additionally if you want to we
could set a number of hyper parameters
for the algorithms here i just use the
default
and then once i have a fitted model
um
i can call fit sorry once i have a
specified model i can call fit on it
pass the training data so both my
features and my target data
and
that will
change the state of this object so it
goes from a specified model to a fitted
model
and once that happened in
i can call predict using the predict
method and pass the the additional test
data that's needed for generating
predictions
and then once i have a prediction i can
compare it against my test set and
look at some
validation metric
and now of course psychic learn offers
much more than this
it offers modular model building so you
can build much more complex models um
with a few lines of code
and for example you can do pipelining
tuning ensembling
and um
yeah you can you can compose
more complex models from
simple components so in this case
we
first standardized the data and then
fit the different algorithms and we put
this together we chained these two
operations together in a pipeline
and the nice thing is that the pipeline
now
is the model itself so it takes in
models but it's also model itself it
still has the fit method with the same
input parameters and the predict method
with the same input parameters
oh i need to import it first
um yes so this is this is what
scikit-learn does in you know a nutshell
in in a very brief summary and i want to
highlight a few points
so first of all
um circuit learn mostly deals with
cross-sectional data
so when we look at the data here there
isn't really a temporal dimension in
this data
and the data wasn't collected over time
and instead the main dimensions are
different kinds of measurements
and
independent
observations so from patients in this
case
another thing i'd like to highlight is
that
um
cyclic learn it mainly covers three
learning tasks and that's
cross-sectional classification
and regression and clustering and the
example above here was regression
and the classification clustering
interface is similar
[Music]
and for each of these learning tasks
cycling provides a common api for the
estimator and this is what the
what essentially fit and predict this
together with a few other
interface points
and these apis when you look at the
signatures of these methods so what are
the input parameters and so on they
closely mirror the learning task that
you're trying to solve
so when you look at the
fit method for example
x here will take in
cross-sectional data
and
y is a
vector
of the target series
and and this is um
[Music]
this mirrors directly the learning tasks
namely the cross-sectional regression
that we want to solve
and you will see the same for
classification
where
the target vector instead of being
consisting of continuous values it
consists of categories
okay so much for psychic learn
and now what we try to do with sk time
is to
take this um to the time series domain
and to generalize this and to extend it
so that we can handle
different time series problems
and as said i will um skip over this
relatively quickly um but if you want
more examples of how these data formats
are different
in the time series domain and
what the different learning tasks are
you can check out the tutorial from the
pi data amsterdam from last year
[Music]
so
when you deal with time series you have
multiple data formats
and the simplest format is that you just
observe a single time series
and that consists of repeated
observations over time
from a single variable or kind of
measurement
so instead of observing data from
multiple patients
um we observe
a single kind of measurement here
from a single punch series and
we can here plot
the number of links trappings for
example over time this would be this
would represent such a univariate time
series
um
of course in many situations we observe
multiple time series at the same time
and this can happen in
in two ways so the first way is
what we call multivariate data
so here you have repeated observations
over time from multiple related
variables or kinds of measurements
so for example here i load the
macroeconomic dataset and i can plot
this
and this shows me some economic
measurements
like the gross national product and the
total employment
and we measure them over the same time
horizon and of course they're closely
related
and
but we can also observe multiple time
series in a different way
namely by um observing repeated
observations
on multiple independent experimental
units
and what i mean by this is
for example the patient data that we had
above but instead of
observing single measurements in time
we now observe for each patient a time
series of measurements
and here in this example
i show you what this would look like
um
each line in this plot represents the
data from a different sample from a
different independent sample that we
have
and
this is what we call panel data
um
so with these different data formats
um
there are different learning tasks or
learning problems that you may encounter
um
for example forecasting so you may want
to predict the future and values of one
of these time series
um you may want to classify these time
series so
for each time series that you observe
you assign a single category or label to
it
you may want to annotate time series so
you may want to assign a label or some
annotation to each time point of the
time series
or you may want to cluster time series
um so you want to
identify and group together similar time
series um this is just a
selection of learning tasks there are
many more
um
but what's interesting about these is
what about these tasks is that while
they are all distinct learning tasks
they also closely related
and i hope that this is that this
becomes clear in this diagram
so what scikit learn covers is
in terms of at least the supervised
learning approaches is tabular
regression and tabular classification
um tabula here meaning cross-sectional
what we try to do with sk time is um to
cover a number of
time series learning tasks
and we will discuss um today we will
discuss class um forecasting classical
forecasting
um time space classification and a
little bit of time series regression
and what we will highlight is that
once you have an algorithm for one of
these problems
you can still use it in many cases to
solve another related problem
for example if you have a time series
classification problem
you can still use a scikit-learn
classifier to solve it
if you do certain
adaptations of the problem
similarly if you have a classical
forecasting problem that you want to
solve
you can still use by following the
arrows on the top
you can still use a regression algorithm
provided by scikit-learn but you need to
be
careful to adapt the problem in the
right way
now this reduction here from classical
forecasting to tabular regression
just to give you one example of what
this looks like is
shown here in the in the diagram and i
will later show this in code as well
um
so we take a single time series and we
cut it up into different segments by
using a sliding window we then stack
them on top of each other
and
this tabularization gives us the
required input format for the
scikit-learn regressor
and we can then put this data into the
circuit loan regressor which is the
little robot
inside the bigger robot
and then once we have this regression
model we can use it to generate
forecasts
so this is one way of still using
scikit-learn
to solve the time series problems and in
sk time we provide dedicated
functionality
to
to make it easy for you to do this
to use these approaches
okay before we dive into the code i want
to quickly give you an overview of what
we're trying to achieve with sk time
um
yeah uh yes i don't know if you want to
put all the or answer all the questions
together because there is a question
that is not being answered i don't know
if you want to be
answering us
oh i didn't see this we can i think the
helpers can take questions
yeah that's the idea um so there's one i
am seeing one is that correct there's
only one i only see one yes but i i
wanted to know it
okay thank you
no thank you thank you for letting us
know
um yes so a quick kind of outlook of or
you know our vision what we're trying to
to achieve with sk time
um
so we're trying to cover multiple
learning tasks and
similar to psychic learn
we're trying to provide a common
estimated api for each of these learning
tasks
and then
like in sklearn each of these apis as we
will see mirrors the the learning
problem
so in terms of the fit and predict
functions and how they are what input
parameters they require
in addition we like to
you know improve the existing ecosystem
of packages
what you will find is that there are
many um
very cool packages out there but it's
still very hard i think to make them
work together to to use them in the same
workflow
and what we try to achieve with sk time
is to make the ecosystem
more interoperable and more usable as a
whole
and we do this by
providing a common api
and then by interfacing existing
packages
so that people can
use um stats models for example or fb
profit or pmd arima um from within sk
time
[Music]
um
[Music]
yes i think i've mentioned this so a lot
of the work that happens in sk time is
this framework development and you will
see shortly what this looks like
and there's also research on algorithm
development happening so if you're
interested in that please feel rich feel
free to reach out to
and of course we're we're building and
growing an open source community with um
of people of
different backgrounds in academia and
industry
and we're giving tutorials like this one
today
now one aspect i want to highlight is
this idea of a framework
um and we will come back to this
um
so
the way i understand the framework is
that we try to collect um
try to develop different design
templates
and by design template i for example
mean the you know
a code skeleton of what a forecasting
algorithm or what a classification
algorithm should look like so what
methods does it need to have in terms of
fit and predict what input parameters do
they take
and we hope that by developing this
framework
it becomes easier to
use and compare different algorithms and
also for you to extend the existing
framework to implement your own
algorithms
okay so that was the introduction
i will now jump
um into the code um
[Music]
and i've opened the second notebook on
forecasting
[Music]
and we will cover um three cases of
forecasting um univariate and this is
the simplest case and then univariate
with exogenous variables and
multivariate forecasting
um
one quick question is this breathable i
should have asked this at the beginning
should i make the the text bigger or can
everyone read this as well
it's readable
okay perfect
um
yes okay so in forecasting what we want
to do is we observe a certain time
series in the past and at a given point
in time we want to make
a prediction about the future values so
in a way we want to make a temporal
forward prediction
[Music]
and the basic workflow so we will
discuss two workflows um the basic one
where we um generate a single prediction
at a single point in time
and then um later we will discuss a more
advanced workflow where we want to
generate predictions repeatedly and as
time as time moves
moves along
[Music]
um so let's start with the basic
workflow
and um
the workflow is very similar to what
we've seen in cycle learn
we first need to specify some data
um we need to specify the learning tasks
so
um
you know what exactly do we want to
predict
we need to specify the model
and then we need to
fit then
fit the model and generate predictions
and evaluate the predictions
so
some example data um
for time series um looks like this
so this is
the number of shampoo sales um
during the 90s
um
so it's a single time series multiple
data points
and we're interested in predicting
future values on this
now in terms of the task specification
um
we know the target series that we want
to predict but what we still need to
predict uh to specify
is
what exact points in the future do we
want to predict
and this is what's called the
forecasting horizon
and so in this case
we will try to predict the last six
months of data
so this is monthly data
um and this is not entirely correct so
this is monthly data so we will um
hold out the last six point of test data
and
we use a six step ahead
um forecasting horizon so at a given
point in time we want to predict the
next six steps ahead
um
yes and then we use some evaluation
metrics in order to quantify how well
we're forecasting
now in sk time
there are different ways to specify this
forecasting horizon
and
we try to make this as convenient as
possible for users when you look at the
ecosystem of packages you will find that
each package has its own way of
specifying the forecasting horizon
so what we try to do in sk time is to
make this as convenient so that you can
use many different ways
um
and
work together with different packages
so very simple ways you just use an
array of a numpy array of values so if i
run this and this could be my
forecasting horizon it just says i want
to you know predict the first step the
second step third step and so on
um
or we have a
forecasting horizon class in sk time
and you can also use that to specify
your forecasting horizon
so in this case i'm saying that i want
to predict um you know these absolute
time points um
[Music]
in the
future and i specify this
is relative faults here
um because i in this case i use absolute
time points that i want to predict
um in comparison to
the relative time points here so these
are always relative to the last point in
my training data
whereas these ones are absolute time
points
um
i can convert between the two
[Music]
so if i have an absolute forecasting
horizon like this one
i can um convert it to a relative one um
at any given cut-off point
so at the end of the training set um
this is the the last data point i have
in the training set so if i run this it
will give me exactly the same
relative forecasting horizon as
specified here
and once we've done this we can do a
train test split um and we can use the
forecasting horizon to do that split
and we can plot the data so this will
now be our test set
and this will be our training set
having done this we can specify model
and
this is the same as in cycle learn so we
instantiate the model we pass any
parameters um that we would like
um into it
in this case it takes a strategy and we
use a drift strategy and we can specify
the window length as well
once we have specified the model we can
then pass the training data
and to give us a fitted model
and now this is a
since this is forecasting we the fit
method
is slightly different to what you're
familiar with from sakura
so note that the
first argument is the target series that
we want to predict because this always
has to be present in forecasting
and then optionally we can pass
exogenous data and we will discuss this
below and
if you'd like you can already pass the
forecasting horizon in fitting
in this case we don't do this
but some models will require the
forecasting horizon already and fitting
so we make it optional whether to pass
it in fit
or in predict
so once you have the
fitted model you can call predict and
the predict signature takes in the
forecasting horizon and
exogenous data and a few other
parameters
and now this is an ease strategy so it
just predicts a linear trend um but you
can see what this prediction looks like
um in comparison to the test data
and then similar to what we do with
circuit learners you can then
compare the prediction against the
the
actual the test data that we have
um and that allows you you know it gives
you some idea of how well this model
will perform
when you deploy it
um
just to give you another example so
this is exactly the same workflow the
only thing that changed is this line
where instead of using an a forecaster i
now use auto reamer
and i specify some additional parameters
um
and it gives me
the prediction from autoring
so it's really easy to try out different
models with the same workflow
the only thing that you have to change
is the specification of the model
and so in summary this is this is the
basic workflow so we use a single fixed
cutoff point
um we generate only a single prediction
um
and sk time provides a common interface
for forecasting tests
with dedicated fit and predict methods
um
is the i just noticed that there's a
sound problem
is that still the case how can everyone
hear me still
i can't hear you all very well
yeah you're good okay
all right perfect
okay
um
yeah so that that's the basic workflow
and we've seen two example forecasters
that you can use the naive one and the
autorimma
now if you want to find out what other
estimates we have in sk time there are
two ways
one is you can go to our website
and
in the documentation you will see an
estimator overview
and this table gives you all of the
estimators that we have in sk time
and if you like you can also filter it
by forecasting for example and this will
give you all of the forecasting
algorithms that we have in sk time
as well as the authors
that created these so if you have
questions it will be easy to find out
who to speak to
the other way is to do it in code so
we have a registry module which
collects all of the estimators that we
have
and from this you can
import a helper function or estimators
and you can run this and you can specify
that you're only interested in
forecasters so you can specify the
estimator types that you're interested
in
and then you will get a list
of the estimators and where you can find
them
in
in sk time so it becomes easy for you to
to find them and to import them
now maybe add the very quick thing
so you can also filter by tags and
there's all the all underscore tags
function
so for instance if you want only
multivariate forecaster
and you can
use all underscore tags to print a list
of the tags and then you look up the tag
for instance that tells you what does it
mean multivariate and you filter by that
uh yes i discussed this a bit later when
we talk about multivariate forecasting
but yes you can filter by estimators and
tax we'll come back to this
yep okay sorry for interrupting then
no problem
um
so at this point you may
wonder um
why um
you know you cannot just use psychedelic
and
this is something we've addressed in the
tutorial from last year um so the answer
is in principle yes you can do cycle
learn
but if you do it naively um there are
many pitfalls so many dangers that you
have to carefully
maneuver around
in order to make sure that your data
science workflow is still
solid and robust
so
as a better solution we suggest to use
cycle learn
with sk time and this brings us back to
the robot diagram which we've seen in
the introduction
um
so if you want to use the cyclic loan
regressor to solve a forecasting problem
we provide dedicated functionality for
this
um and this will take care of all of the
additional data transformations
and
the application of the fitted regressor
um automatically so you don't have to
worry about this
and what's nice about this is that it
makes the
the use of psychic learn for forecasting
very modular and and and easy for you
it also makes it parametric and tunable
so
in this transformation there are certain
parameters like the window length when i
apply this lighting window here to chop
up my time series into
you know equal blocks
and the window length is a hyper
parameter that i as a user have to
specify
if i do this naively it may be very hard
to tune this
so with sk time it becomes easily
tunable
and the nice thing is once you've done
this
um once you once you um
if you use square time um the regressor
itself
um if you wrap it in an sk time class
behaves as if it were a forecaster so
you can still easily compare it to other
forecasting algorithms without having to
write any extra code
so let me show you um how this is done
in sk time
so here we just load another
time series so this gives you the the
number of airline passengers again it's
a monthly data and it's we've collected
this data over the years
um
we do the same thing again we
split our data and specify a forecasting
horizon in this case we're interested in
predicting the last 12 months
so the next year ahead
and now let's assume that we want to use
k nearest neighbors from scikit lan
in order to use that um
we first
specify the circuit learn model this is
what we do in this line
and we can use any hyper parameters that
we like
and then we use the helper from from sk
time
and what this function does is it
returns a forecaster
that internally uses the regressor
and
you can specify how you want that to
happen
so this encapsulates
this forecaster here
encapsulates
you know is represented by this diagram
so inside we have the regressor and the
outside robot is the forecaster itself
um and you can specify different
parameters um
of how you want to do this
um
so if we run this um so you have
different options for the exact strategy
um
so and that that includes a direct
strategy recursive strategy or
multi-output strategies
um and you can read up on them um
we provide the link to your nice paper
that explains you what they mean
um and you can specify the the window
length
of how many you know when you do this
the sliding wind operation how long
should that window be
um
yes so with these parameters specified
we then get a forecaster and as said the
forecaster has exactly the same
interface as any of the other
forecasters in sk time so it becomes
really easy to
um to train and predict them
so in this case um
we passed the data again
and since we passed the forecasting
horizon here already in fit we don't
need to pass and predict the model will
remember and generate the prediction for
you
and this is what the prediction looks
like and so it's um
the k nearest neighbor's prediction um
using the recursive strategy
[Music]
and do this becomes a forecaster
in okay so this is um
you know
the the basic workflow
for a single cutoff point
um
[Music]
and i'd now like to look at the more
advanced workflow and that you may
encounter
in
in real world applications
and
the advanced workflow is as follows so
again we specify the data the task and
the model that we want to use
we then again fit and predict the model
on the training data
but once we have generated the first
prediction
in practice we often observe new data
coming in as time moves on and
as time progresses we want to generate a
new prediction and at the same time make
use of the latest data that we have
so we observe new data
then we want to update our existing
model using that new data
and once we have the updated model we
want to generate a new prediction so we
repeat the steps five to seven
as as as time progresses
so let's see how how this works in
skytime
um
we start off in by
again loading some data um and then
specifying um the tasks that we want to
predict
um
[Music]
so in this case
we are interested still in predicting
the next year um the 12 steps ahead
and then we need to select our training
data
and here we say that our training data
um consists of the data up to the um
up to august and 1957
so somewhere here
and this is at this point in time
and that will also be all of the data
that we've observed
and so here i just predict that i just
print out the tail so this is you know
the la the last few observations that
we've made
and once we have this data um we then
specify a model
in this case i use the auto ets model
um
and then i fit the model um on the
training data
so this is so far it's the same as the
basic workflow
and then once i have a fitted model i
want to generate
the first prediction
and this is what it looks like
so at this point in time
in um
[Music]
in
so let's look at the the predicted
values actually
yes so the the notes here aren't correct
so
um at the time it at august in 57 we now
predicted the next year ahead up to
august 58.
um
okay and now in
in a live process we would then observe
the next data point
so we're in august 57
and we then observe um
september 57
and this is what we simulate here
so our observed data
um
is now goes up to
september 57
and our new data point is
exactly that
observation for september 57
and now what we can then do with this in
sk time is we have our fitted model
and we can then pass the new data point
to the fitted model
and that will update the model
now in this case you get a warning and
there are different ways of how this
updating can work
now very
simple strategy is to just refit the
entire model based on the
all of the observed data that you have
but in some cases um there are more
efficient algorithms
that instead of refitting the entire
model they use the fitted model and then
some specific updating algorithm
to update the parameters without
refitting the model as a whole
once we have updated the model we can
then generate a new prediction still for
the same forecasting horizon
and you will see that this
still gives us a prediction for the next
12 months but it's now
it has now moved
up by one month so the first month that
we predict here is october and whereas
previously the first month was september
um
yes i've i've printed the docstring for
update here
[Music]
and
it as said it's um the fallback option
is to refit the model as a whole
um
you could also use this update method um
to just um
generate forecasts for
and new new cutoff points so as time
moves on you always want to predict the
next 12 years at 12 months
um but perhaps you don't want to update
the fitted parameters of your model
actually
perhaps you're happy with the
fitted parameters from your initial
training set
and while you still want to always
predict new
um you know make new predictions you
want to do this without updating
so you can do this by setting the update
params parameter to false
and and you can of course also use um
exogenous data and we will discuss this
below
um now this was a
you know a manual
step through the process so we stepped
through it
manually and
and in sk time we have lots of
functionality to help you automating
this so that you can simulate this
process during model development
and evaluate your models
and in particular what we have is an
evaluate function and we have window
splitters
that allow you to
split the time series iteratively
and
so to give you an example
um
if we want to do this kind of temporal
cross validation we could use the
expanding window splitter
and we say we have a step length of
three so every new window will be three
steps ahead
and we have an initial window of ten
time points
and then if we plot the windows
um it would look like this so the first
windmill consists of 10 time points
and then we have our forecasting horizon
of 12 time points
and then we step by three
to get the next window and since it's an
expanding window and we keep the all of
the previous data points in the window
and we have a dedicated notebook for
this if you want to find out more about
the different
um windows splitters and
different ways of doing temporal cross
validation
and
now we can use this to
evaluate
forecasters in this advanced workflow
what we need to do for this is again we
specify model
in this case we're using the naive
forecast again
and we then need to specify the
the way how we want to split the model
and the way how we would use it in
practice
and we can then pass on all of this
information
to
the evaluate function
and that will do this
update predict loop um internally
automatically
and we can look at the results
so this just shows that the first result
but you will see that
those are the metrics from the first
window that we had
which we specified to be 72 um
data points long
and then
we had a step length of 12
so we for every new window we add 12
data points and we get the corresponding
um
evaluation metrics
so to visualize this
um
we could look at it like this so we
the up to this point
and that's our training set
um we train our algorithm on that data
we generate the first prediction and
compare it against the actual data
we then move 12 steps ahead
and
update our algorithm with all of the
past data make a prediction for the next
12 steps and compare it against the
actual data and we do this repeatedly
um
yes so that's the
that's the more advanced workflow
and
what i want to talk about next is the
um advanced model building and
composition functionality in sk time
and and i said these models can be used
in either workflow
and um
i want to talk specifically about tuning
and
about pipelining
so in tuning we're interested in
optimizing
some of the parameters and
some of the hyper parameters that we
need to specify during model
construction
for example when we use the
make reduction
helper function we had to specify the
window length
and that may be a parameter that we want
to optimize because we may not know what
a the best parameter is
so we can use temporal cross validation
um
to find the the best parameter from the
data that we have
and this is very similar to how circuit
learn does it so we specify a parameter
grid
here our grid consists of different
window length and
also of different parameters for the
regressor that we use so the k nearest
neighbor progressor has one of the
parameters are the number of neighbors
um and we want to tune them
simultaneously
um our cross temp our
in
our temporal cross validation scheme is
we want to use a sliding window splitter
and we specify the window length of each
of each window
and the same forecasting horizon
now with all of that information we can
then pass this to our forecasting grid
search cv
and
we can then pass the training data and
fit and
the forecasting horizon and predict
and that will
try out all of the different parameter
combinations
and
generate predictions and
evaluate them and then pick the best one
so once that's finished running and we
can
look at what the the best parameters are
and
in this case it chooses um the number of
estimators to be 2 and the window length
to be 12.
so maybe a quick question because i'm
also not sure here myself the window
length here
that's the window length in the
reduction not the window length in the
sliding window splitter right
that's correct so the the sliding window
splitter
is um the
that specifies the way how we want to
evaluate this
whereas the window length here specifies
in our model
so we do nested sliding windows windows
inside windows
right yes in a way yes yep one one
sliding window operation is part of the
model itself that's the reduction
operation
and
one sliding window operation is part of
the evaluation scheme
[Music]
thanks
um and this again this this visualizes
the you know parts of the data in this
sliding window scheme so each window
here is what did we specify
a length of 60
and then we always have the forecasting
horizon as the next 12 steps ahead
and that was a
simpler tuning example
in some cases you would like to not just
tune the parameters the hyperparameters
of the forecasters that you use but you
would also like to
you know compare different models um
themselves
and this is sometimes you know what
comes under the name of auto mill
and we also have a dedicated
functionality for this
so in this example here
what we're interested is what we're
interested in is to find out
which of these forecasting algorithms um
is is the better one for our prediction
task
and we can use this multiplex forecaster
to specify
for to specify the choices of algorithms
or the selection of algorithms that we
want to compare
and then
tune over this grid of of um over that
selection
and
the workflow is the same we specify the
grid search pass over all of the
parameters and then call fit and predict
um
and in this case it selects the
exponential smoothing over the naive
forecaster
um another way to build more complicated
models is pipelining so in pipe learning
you first transform the data
and then you
fit the forecast on the transform data
um
and during prediction you first generate
the forecast and then you inverse
transform the forecast so that you come
back to the original
um
dimension of the data the original scale
of the data
and in sk time we can do this as follows
so if we're interested in transforming
the target series
um
we can
specify a list of um transformers and
the final forecaster
so in this case we first
analyze the data
um we do trend it so we we remove the
the linear trend
and then we fit the forecaster on that d
seasonalized and d trend of data
once we put everything into a pipeline
and
that pipeline behaves the same as any
other forecaster
and so we can just
call fit and predict on it
oh i need to import it first
um
[Music]
yeah i'm not showing the prediction
again but the idea is the same
so that was the univariate forecasting
scenario
one variation that you often find is
that you have additional exogenous data
so you have a
a single target series which sometimes
also is called endogenous data
um and you observe that data only in the
past
but in addition you have one or more
related
exogenous time series and you observe
them in the past but also for the period
in the future that you're interested in
predicting
so
in in many cases you may observe some
other variable
um
into the future so that could be
calendar information that you can just
look up in the calendar like whether
someday in the future will be a public
holiday
or it could be some other variable that
may be easier to predict
um than the target variable that you're
interested in predicting
so you can use the prediction for the
one variable in order to predict the
other variable
um okay let's quickly go through this in
the in the basic workflow
um so here we load a data set with
exogenous data so we have a single
target series
and we have a number of related time
series
and
the workflow is the same we specify a
forecasting horizon and split the data
this time both the target series and the
exogenous data
and then we specify model and we pass
the the exogenous data as our x um
to the fit method
and then in predict we need to pass the
additional
exogenous data
for the
that corresponds to the forecasting
horizon
um
to generate the prediction
um
and then for the target series we get a
prediction and now this uses both the
past data of the target series but also
the
contemporaneous exogenous data
pipelining
also works with exogenous data
so
when i scroll up here we transform the
target series
using this pipeline
but in some cases we may also want to
transform the exogenous data that we
have
and for this we have a forecasting
pipeline
and so here i'm loading some other
macroeconomic data
i'm
specifying the forecasting horizon and
splitting the data
and then we can specify pipeline so if
there's missing data we may want to
impute the data first
um
we may want to scale the data using
different approaches
and what i use here is an adapter so i
have to wrap it into this class
because this transformer here comes
directly from scikit-learn
and you can still use any circuit learn
transformer
by just wrapping it into this class and
it will
work within the the forecasting api
and
after these transformations um i yet
then use the auto reima model
and as before i can call fit and predict
and the only difference is that these
transformations will now be applied to
the exogenous data rather than to my
target series
and and you get a prediction
okay um
so so far we've discussed in
the simplest case univariate forecasting
and
univariate forecasting with um exogenous
data
another forecasting problem is
multivariate forecasting
and what we want to do here is we want
to predict multiple series
at the same time
and this is what um franz mentioned um
so
if you're using sk time
and you want to solve a multivariate
forecasting problem you may wonder what
kinds of algorithms can handle this this
kind of problem
so you want to specify the estimated
type to be a forecaster
but you don't want any forecaster
because you only need those forecasters
that can handle
um certain types of input data
so what you can do is you can specify
the tags
so in sk time all of the estimators that
we have
have a tag or have multiple tags and
these tags describe them further
so
one tag is for example
the type of the y data that can be
accepted and this can be univariate
multivariate or both
and if we're interested in multivariate
forecasting we would set this to
multivariate and both
um
and then again we get a list of the
the algorithms in sk time that can
handle this kind of data
now to show you
two examples um we first load in some
data
and we split the data and now what i
should show here is that um
[Music]
if you look at y train
it consists of of two time series
and we're interested in predicting both
of them at the same time
now a very simple approach is you could
say
um i know that these two time series are
related but i still want to predict both
of them
separately so i know they have some
relation and
using that relation may be a good idea
but
as a baseline i just want to predict
both of them separately
and this is what we call um
[Music]
by column or by variable ensembling
and we have a class for this the column
ensemble forecaster
so you can say that for the first column
so the you know index 0 here
i want to use a polynomial trend
forecaster
and for the second column i want to use
exponential smoothing
um i pass these forecasters to the
ensemble i pass my now multivariate
training data and it will fit this model
on the first column and the exponential
smoothing on the second column
and then return the predictions from it
so at this point i haven't made use of
you know the
the any information that's in the
in having both of the series
um in their relationship
and but it may still be a good starting
point
and now if you want to use more more
complicated models um
you can take a list of the ones that we
already have
this is also an active area of
development in sk time
so we're we're working on adding more of
these models over time
now one
common model is the vector
auto regressive model
and we use um this we under the hood we
use um
stats models
um
but we allow you if you import the vsk
time
it uses stats models under the hood but
it allows you to follow the same
workflow as for any of the other models
so you can
specify the model um
if you like you can i need to import it
first if you like you can specify
any of the parameters that you know from
stats models
um but you have the same interface um
as for any of the other forecasters in
sk time
and you will then get a prediction from
the
the vector or the regressive model in
sk2
and
yes and this this brings us to the end
of the
the overview of the forecasting
functionality
um
now what's really nice about sktime and
this brings us back to the the framework
idea is
that
we provide specific algorithms
so
toolbox functionality that you can just
import and use directly
but we also provide a design template
that you can follow and if you follow
that um all of the code that you write
will be compatible
with the other functionality in sk time
and
the way we do this is we have extension
templates
so when you go i should start here when
you go to the main repository of sk time
you will find a folder called extension
templates
and in here you have the files for the
different learning problems that we
currently cover so if you click on the
forecasting one
you will find a detailed description of
you know how a forecaster what how you
need to implement it so that it's
compatible
with all of the other functionality in
sk time
[Music]
and we also provide a code skeleton so
you can just copy the code that you find
here
and then work through it and
change whatever it says to do
[Music]
um
and that gives you you know the the the
ability and makes it really easy for you
to implement your own algorithm your
custom algorithms
um which are still fully compatible
with the rest of sk time
um okay so in summary
we
talked about sktime having a unified api
for univariate forecasting and
multivariate forecasting
um
i've shown you some examples in of how
we interface other packages
but expose them through a common api and
so we've seen psychic learn
and we've seen stats models um the auto
reamer class that we've used the user's
pmd area under the hood and um i think
there are a number of other packages
like profit um but also t-baths and so
on
and this is still work in progress we're
still trying to add um
integrations with other models
um we've also seen and how you can build
complicated or you know composite models
um in a modular fashion so we've seen
pipelines we've seen ensembles
we've seen
tuna
and we've seen reduction
and um
i've quickly shown you you know if you
want to build your own model
and hopefully it's it's easy to do that
and then at the end here i i list a
number of other useful resources
but you will also find them in the
in the previous tutorial
so at this point i suggest we take a
quick break um perhaps three minutes
um three to five minutes
um if you have any questions feel free
to ask them
and then after the break we jump into
the classification notebook
okay
it's 43
um
and i'm going to continue with the
classification part so we have roughly
15 minutes left um
so
i may skip over to some of the things in
this notebook but you can always um try
to run through it on your own and then
if you have any questions
ask them
um on the slack on the pi data slack or
you can
get in touch with us on our github
repository we have our own slack space
and a few other communication channels
and you're more than welcome to to raise
issues there or to get in touch with us
now classification is quite a different
learning test so
what we're interested in here is we have
a training data set where we observe
multiple time series and they come from
from independent
experimental units
and for each of them we observe some
category or some label
um
so in this case it's the color
we have one time series with a blue
label and two with a red label
and the goal is to
train an algorithm which can then
predict the label
of a new unlabeled series
[Music]
the workflow though is is very similar
to what we've seen in in sk learn
so we specify the data the task
we then specify the model and then we
fit in
the predict
um
what we use in this
tutorial on this notebook is um
some time series and data set from the
ucr uea
repository
and this is uh
i've added the link here
this is a
and on a website which has lots of time
series classification data sets
um
and the table for you to to look them up
and to
you know it always has some description
on it as well
um
what we have in sk time is a helper
function
that allows you to easily download data
from the website and then it stores it
locally
so that you can
make use of that data
[Music]
so we first load the data
and then we for convenience we converted
um
to a 3d numpy array
um
we have a
like a common
function for this that hopefully makes
it easy for you to convert between
different data formats
when you have this kind of panel data
um
there are many different ways of how you
can format this you can use a pandas
data frame you can use numpy you can use
other ways
and with this function we try to
provide some conversion functionality so
that you can easily
load the data in whatever format you
have it and then convert it so that you
can use it in sk time
so we load our x
our feature data
and
our target series here is
consists of two kinds of labels
and so it's a binary
so they should say binary
it's a binary
classification problem
now what does this data look like
here i plot
two of the time series
one for each label
[Music]
and this is some data on italy power
demand and you're trying to predict
whether this time series occurred in the
summer or in the winter and here just
show one example
for each of the labels
um
now the workflow i said is very similar
to circuit learn we first split the data
and we then specify the model so
in this case i use um rocket and you can
find out more about what the algorithm
does there is the repository of the
original code but it has also been
ported into sk time like many other
algorithms
and there's a nice blog post here that
explains you more intuitively what the
algorithm does
so we specify the model
and
and we then fit the data
so we fit the algorithm passing the data
now when you look at the fit method it
looks um almost identical to the circuit
learn method but there is one key
difference
namely this
x here is no longer
it no longer represents cross-sectional
data
but it now represents panel data
so what you passed
in as the feature data
is um
not a data table as we've seen in the in
the introduction
but it's a data table with which has
some
time index so you observe for multiple
experimental units you observe something
over time
and all of the time series classifiers
in sk time they need
that kind of panel data
so they are specialized algorithms to
work with panel data
once we have a fitted classifier we can
pass the test panel data
and
we get a prediction out of it and then
since it's a classification problem we
can use circuit learns
you know classification metrics here we
look at the accuracy score
and we will see that it predicts 97 of
the
the series and the test set correctly
as before you can
if you want to find out what classifiers
and we have an sk time you can use the
estimators function
and that will give you
a long list of um
dedicated time series classifiers
again you may ask um whether you could
not just use psychic learn
and here the answer is in principle yes
but research has shown that
[Music]
using cross-sectional algorithms may not
be as powerful as using dedicated time
series classification algorithms
and at the bot at the bottom of this
notebook i provide some links and for
different benchmarking experiments
um and you can also see um
more info on this in our previous
tutorial
from the pilot amsterdam
but if you still want to use circuit
learn and that's fine and you can do
that with sk time
now again the problem that we're trying
to solve is a time series classification
problem so there needs to be some
conversion to make it um to adapt it to
the classification and to the
cross-sectional classification setting
in cycle then
um but we provide functionality for this
so you can use the tabularizer
to convert the data from panel data to
cross-sectional data and then as before
you can use any any cyclone classifier
to solve the problem
and in some cases it may work well in
other cases they may not so in this case
it performs slightly worse than the
dedicated time series algorithm
and we also have
um advanced model building functionality
for time sleeve classification
so you can do pipelining ensemble tuning
um i've shown you an example of
reduction here
and this works very much as it works
with circuit land in fact we use the
pipeline
class from scikit lab
so quick quick question i think someone
is asking can you print out x-train
just for
showing how it looks like here yes
that's a good question let me do this
quickly
so
i said they are different
in
different ways of representing this kind
of data
here we have it as a
three-dimensional numpy array so what
does this mean so
it means that we have
data on
you know
over a thousand experimental units so
for example patients
and for each of them we observe one kind
of measurement so one variable
and we observe that variable over time a
for 24 time points
but as said there are other ways to
represent this data
this is what we call the numpy 3d
representation
um i hope i hope this this answers the
question
um
yeah so and you know we have pipelining
um
and of course you know another way to to
use circuit learn is if you have time
series data you first extract features
and then you fit some circuit learn
regressor classifier on it and
here um we use the tears fresh
feature extractor so t is fresh is a
package
um which is dedicated um
which you you know which provides
automated feature extraction
and
that allows you to easily
you know extract features and use
circuit learn
um to solve the time series
classification problem
um
now very closely related learning task
is time stage regression
the only difference here is that the
target series
the target variable does not consist of
continuous variance sorry does not
consist of categories but of continuous
values as with you know cross-sectional
classification and regression
[Music]
so what i want to show you is that first
of all the workflow is still the same we
can we can load the data
um
here plot the distribution of the target
variable
here i plot some of the time series of
the feature data
and we can still use the same
functionality so
here we use um part of the rocker
classifier so just the kind of the
time series processing step and then we
use a random forest progressor
and that still works in the same way
but we can also um come back to our
reduction example
and instead of using a tabular regressor
in here we can use a time series
regressor
so we still convert the data but when
you look at the
the data here
it
is in a way it is panel data because we
have multiple rows of data and in each
row we have a time series
so we could use a
cross-sectional progressor but we could
also use a
time series regressor
and to do this we can use the same
function as before the make reduction
function
the only thing that we have to change
is
we have to specify the site type
of the estimator and in this case
we want to say it's not a tabular
regressor but it's a time series
regressor that we're using
marcus and
yep we only have a few minutes left i'm
sorry
yes i know we want to wrap up thank you
yep thanks thanks for letting me know
thank you
um
so this what i wanted to show with this
is that there's this this is another
relationship between different learning
tasks and how we can reuse an algorithm
for one problem to solve another one
[Music]
and
the final topic i wanted to talk about
was multivariate times to use
classification
and i've added some notes here
so perhaps this is something
we leave
for youtube to play around with in your
own time
one last
thing that's worth highlighting is that
in sk time we have many of the
state-of-the-art timesheet
classification algorithms
so the the current state of the art i
think is
an algorithm called hive code version
two
um
and that has been implemented in sk time
so um if you want to try this out in
practice and it's also basically really
easy for you to try
and as before
we have um
extension templates so if you want to
build your own your custom classifier
that's fully compatible with the rest of
sk time
you can use the template
and at the bottom here i
have a number of additional resources
that you may find interesting for
example the benchmarking
and the link to our deep learning
package where we provide them deep
learning algorithms
um
okay
um
so that was uh you know a quick tour of
the the classification module in sk time
before you go before we go um
i quickly want to give you an outlook of
what's on the roadmap
so let's switch back to the presentation
so
on the roadmap
the following topic so
we want to
add support for time series clustering
and there's already an experimental
module
and and we will further consolidate this
and hopefully provide time to use
clustering functionality
um
in a you know in a robust state sometime
soon
someone asked in the chat already about
anomaly and outlier detection um
especially in the setting of in the
forecasting setting
and this is also work in progress um
there are um
there's an open pull request for this
and there's some basic functionality in
sk time already
and there's active work on
other forecasting tasks like
hierarchical forecasting and panel
forecasting
and finally um we
continue to work with other
package maintainers in the ecosystem
um to
work towards a more unified
api for for solving these different
learning problems
and for making the ecosystem more
interoperable and usable
as a whole
now the very last thing
um
that i want to show you in the last
minutes is
um
our website um if you want to find out
more about sktime and if you want to get
involved
um you can um
read more about this here
so we have a number of activities
happening almost every week and we have
a mentoring scheme
um so if you're new to contributing to
open source or to machine learning with
time series
um we you can apply and we will try to
connect you with one of the more
experienced developers
and so that you can make your first
contribution to sk time
um and we have a number of meetups
um
that you can find out about here so we
have a calendar
of the different activities that are
happening
um we have weekly collaborative coding
sessions we have different meetups on
roadmap planning
and you're welcome to attend any of
these
your feedback as users or developers is
always appreciated
and i think we're at the end of at the
time yes thank you very much marcus and
your team
thank you everybody who came and i hope
you have enjoyed it and i'm gonna stop
the meeting the recording and the
meeting thank you very much
bye thank you bye